guau lo logré no puedes creerlo pero me
tardé bastante en hacer esta gráfica y
al menos es lo mejor que me ha podido
quedar esta gráfica con esta mano
bastante temblorosa que tengo espero que
no te moleste pero representa bastante
bien o al menos un poco mejor la gráfica
que viene en el siguiente problema que
es el problema número 15
estamos en el problema número 15 que es
este de aquí y por cierto aquí me faltan
algunos puntos déjenme ponerlos de una
vez este de aquí va a ser mi punto p
este de aquí va a ser mi punto q y bueno
este es el eje de las x este es el eje
de las 10 y este no olvides que es el
origen es el 0 0 y además me dan las dos
ecuaciones de estas dos curvas de estas
dos parábolas déjenme notar las aquí
porque son bastante importantes
esta es la parábola clásica y es igual a
x cuadrada mientras que esta de aquí es
la parábola y es igual
am - x cuadrada - x cuadrado muy bien y
bueno una vez que sabemos todo esto hay
además nos dan esta distancia esta
distancia que hay de aquí hasta acá toda
esta distancia es 6 unidades y entonces
nos dicen que si dado pq igual las seis
unidades cuanto vale a lo que queremos
saber es el valor de amd esta es mi
pregunta y bueno para sacar el valor de
amd lo que quiero que te des cuenta y lo
más importante de este problema es que
estas dos son parábolas simétricas es
decir que si nosotros ponemos un espejo
en el eje de las 'íes' se va a ver lo
mismo de ambos lados son parábolas que
se están reflejando bajo el eje de las
diez parábolas simétricas eso quiere
decir que si nosotros nos fijamos en la
distancia que hay de aquí acá esta
distancia debe de ser tres unidades y si
nos fijamos en la distancia que hay de p
a este punto también debe de ser tres
unidades o dicho de otra manera como
este es el punto cero entonces si
nosotros bajamos para acá este punto q
tiene como valor en x 3
este punto tiene como coordenada en x 3
mientras que este otro punto tiene como
coordenada menos 3 porque estamos antes
del origen este punto tiene como
coordenada menos 3 en x cuál es el valor
de y pues no lo sabemos pero lo que sí
sabemos es que estos dos puntos están en
estas dos parábolas tanto en ésta como
en esta es decir que estos dos puntos
cumplen ambas para hablar
simultáneamente o dicho de otra manera
tanto el punto p como el punto q son la
intersección de estas dos ecuaciones y
esto quiere decir que x cuadrada tiene
que ser igual
a - x cuadrada porque el valor de james
en ambas parábolas debe de ser lo mismo
en estos puntos
esto por estos puntos y bueno si x
cuadrada es igual a menos x cuadrada un
equipo de sumar x cuadrada de ambos
lados de la ecuación voy a sumar x
cuadrada de este lado voy a sumar x
cuadrada de este lado estos dos se van y
me queda que es igual a 2 x cuadrado y
ya estamos a punto de acabar este
problema porque yo sé que en estos
puntos en estos puntos importantes se
cumple que es igual a 2 x cuadrada pero
habíamos dicho que estos puntos tienen
como valor en x 3 o menos 3 entonces am
es igual a 2 por 3 al cuadrado lo cual
es lo mismo a es igual a 2 por 9 a es
igual a 18 y pasaría lo mismo si
pusiéramos el valor de menos tres menos
3 al cuadrado también nos da 9 y 2 por 9
18 por lo tanto la respuesta correcta es
que a es igual a 18 y esto lo logramos
dándonos cuenta de dos cosas importantes
la primera es que estamos hablando de
parábolas simétricas y por lo tanto esta
distancia es 3 y esta distancia es 3 y
la segunda es que nos dimos cuenta de
que en estos puntos se intersectan mis
dos palabras y por lo tanto estos puntos
son especiales porque tienen que tener
el mismo valor para ella en esta
ecuación y en esta ecuación y una vez
que igualamos estas dos ecuaciones
llegamos al valor de amd perfecto vamos
a hacer el siguiente problema borramos
la pantalla y vamos a hacer el problema
número 16 y dice el conjunto x tiene x
elementos el conjunto ya tiene y
elementos y el conjunto z tienen los
elementos del conjunto x y los elementos
del conjunto james excepto sus elementos
comunes
cuántos elementos tiene z
esto me suena conjuntos y por lo tanto
vamos a intentar resolverlo con un
diagrama de ven y para resolverlo por un
diagrama de ven déjenme tomar este de
aquí vamos a tomar un color agradable y
voy a decir que este es mi conjunto x a
no esto no me va a servir este es mi
conjunto x muy bien y también tenemos un
conjunto y así que déjame tomar otro
color y voy a decir que este es mi
conjunto y tengo estos dos conjuntos así
que vamos a ponerles nombre este de aquí
es mi conjunto x este es mi conjunto x
mientras que éste es mi conjunto y éste
aquí es mi conjunto gemma y por cierto x
tiene x elementos que tiene y elementos
y dicen que x y tienen acá elementos
comunes es decir que justo aquí en medio
hay acá elementos comunes tenemos acá
elementos repetidos entre estos dos y
además el problema dice que el conjunto
z tiene todos los elementos del conjunto
x todos los elementos del conjunto james
excepto los elementos que tienen en
común por lo tanto déjame ver si lo
puedo poner de un cierto color vamos a
ponerlos con este color y este y este va
a ser la cantidad de elementos que
tengan mi conjunto z ahora mi pregunta
es cuántos elementos hay en esta parte
que acabo de mostrarte entonces
fijémonos en el conjunto x el conjunto x
tiene x elementos pero ya hay aquí cada
elementos por lo tanto aquí afuera debe
de haber x menos k elementos recuerda
que la suma de estos ojos tienen que dar
ex elementos entonces vamos bien y vamos
a fijarnos en el conjunto y en el
conjunto que tiene y elementos pero ya
contamos cada elementos en esta parte
por lo tanto en esta otra parte que está
asombrada la que acabamos de colorear
debe de haber ya menos cada elementos
aquí debe de haber menos que elementos y
ahora sí si nos fijamos en el conjunto z
conjunto z debe de tener x menos que
elementos más o menos cada elementos es
decir la cantidad de elementos que hay
en x excepto los repetidos más la
cantidad de elementos que hay en excepto
los repetidos y esto cuánto es pues esto
es lo mismo que x más bien menos 2 k que
por cierto esta es la respuesta del
inciso d entonces ya está es el inciso
de y espero que te hayas divertido nos
vemos pronto